nouveau mouvement déclenché ce matin à
paris les ouvriers les techniciens des
théâtres lyriques nationaux opéra et
opéra comique ont décidé une grève
illimitée avec occupation des locaux et
des banderoles revendicatives sont
apparus ce matin sur le palais garnier
parmi leurs revendications augmentation
des salaires abolition des ordonnances
sur la sécurité sociale et création d'un
comité de cogestion cet après midi le
personnel du théâtre national populaire
le tnp s'est joint à ce mouvement
d'autre part les personnels des services
de nettoiement de la ville de paris ont
également décidé une grève illimitée
avec occupation des locaux de leur
entreprise
en ce qui concerne la ratp le trafic du
métro est nulle et le trafic des bus est
arrêté dans l'après midi
vingt-et-une ligne de remplacement par
camion militaire gratuits seront mis en
place dès demain matin dans le sens
banlieue paris à la sncf le trafic est
nul sur l'ensemble du réseau et les
gares parisiennes sont désertes
et le dimanche des ouvriers de renault à
boulogne billancourt s'est déroulé en
compagnie de pia colombo et de leny
escudero le comité d'établissement de la
régie renault qui avait prévu pour
aujourd'hui sa fête annuelle de
l'enfance a en effet déplacé cette fête
devant les portes de l'usiné occupée en
raison des difficultés de transport et
afin de distraire les ouvriers ainsi que
leurs familles venus leur rendre visite